state your name for the record Wade
Barnes night of January 31st all of the
damage was done I'll touch the water
months passed before anyone comes out to
fix anything I wake up and there is a
huge water stain on the ceiling he took
a single finger and then he just bounced
on his bed ooh water is just flowing out
and I am just sitting there shaking it
stay away from the water the house
soiled all over him we all just stood
there stop
we're not supposed to be here well the
inside of our house is being put back
together the outside decided to go on a
full-out rebellion you ever seen a
whirlpool form in your street oh man a
house a wife two dogs one cat what does
it mean is a start
I'm sorry did you say a rule form in
your stream yeah we looked outside and I
could not believe what laid before me
the water I'm gonna stop you a world as
in the thing that forms in the ocean or
the sea was in your street yeah the
water had to have been three feet high
at least as you can see this face of the
mailbox here comes up two or three feet
on me the water came all the way up to
this bar at one point the water flooded
all the way up to read about this line
just before this line with this house
nothing is done June 19th
the very next day the painters show up
to fix the house we walk into the living
room they look at the ceiling and
everything looks good they can paint so
I opened the double doors the double
doors that lead into where JP was
covered in [ __ ] and what I saw nearly
killed me on the spot the ceiling was
dripping and soaked again and that drip
had to be a prank it had to be someone
someone was messing with someone was
[ __ ] with me this could not be really
happening again the day the painters
show up rewinding back to May 22nd it's
fixed
Jay the drywalling is done June 19th
they show up to paint and that day
the leak is back because the house
doesn't want to be fixed so we call the
plumber
again the painters are working and the
other room the plumber comes in and
complete disbelief that he's at our
house for these same toilet and ceiling
again he cuts open the ceiling the pipe
is fine he goes upstairs to the toilet
there's the water on the floor beneath
the tank his best explanation was well
we came in and we took off the toilet
twice it had to put it back one of those
times the nuts and the bolts in the
bottom of the toilet tank must have come
loose never seen that happen before like
this no but it happens here places the
bolts he stays for two hours to dry out
the ceiling dry off the pipe to behind
the floor to make sure that there's not
a single leak he came to me for payment
yada yada and said all right I'm 100%
confident but the leak is fixed the pipe
is secure the bolts are secure
everything is as fixed as it can be but
in your house
I'm maybe 99% sure it's fixed so a month
goes by no more drips no more water
stains but our hopes were to be dashed
yet again when the house decided that it
was bored and wanted to strike again
[Applause]
[Music]
mid late July the dates get a little bit
muddy here for me because it's kind of
recent it all just honestly blurs
together was the start
yeah that does Wednesday night we
noticed that we were sleeping on top of
the covers that might be our a/c wasn't
keeping the house as cool as we were
liked because of the heat wave coming in
Thursday comes and I gotta check the
thermostat because it feels hotter than
it should and the thermostat says it's
81 degrees in the house that's weird
set to 70 that can't be right so I turn
the a/c down more turn it down to 65
it's 81 in fact that climbs up to 83 and
then it climbs to 84 85 peaking at 86
degrees I call it an air conditioning
repair company and a guy comes out and
he spends three hours working on the a/c
unit on the phone various different
people trying to figure out how our
particular a/c unit works I guess and
after all this time I heard the words I
dread the most I don't know what's wrong
call somebody else get a second opinion
so on Friday I called somebody else to
the first guy's credit he gave me some
other numbers to try and one of them
panned out they sent someone out to come
check out the a/c unit even though I
gave them that guy's best guesses as to
what went wrong I gave them the make the
model the year of the a/c unit he shows
up with no parts with which to fix the
unit what time can they squeeze me in
435 gets there at 5:00
figures out what's wrong the only place
that sells parts for you a secure AC
unit they closed at 5:00 guess you'll
have to wait till Monday during the
hottest heatwave to hit Cincinnati all
year I mean we're talking like a hundred
degrees plus 100 percent humidity
outside inside it was no longer cold the
house was cooking
[Music]
you got a demon living in this house can
you get it out
oh my job I'm only here to tell the
story the why the how the my department
how to get rid of it like a priest or
something maybe do you believe in that
sort of thing I didn't believe in demons
until you just had one demon is just a
word it describes an idea the idea it's
the truth behind of it and that's what
you have to pass okay you're confused
yeah it's because so Monday morning
comes around
we're expecting Molly's parents to show
up Tuesday we need to get the ACU
working nobody shows up 10:00 10:30 in
the morning I call them desperate to get
the AC back online and I'm told well I
didn't know they were supposed to come
back out the earliest we can get
somebody out there's tomorrow Tuesday
Wednesday night no AC unit
Thursday Friday Saturday Sunday Monday
six days and the hottest period in
Cincinnati our pets are laying around
chanting miserable can't move Molly and
I carrying fans with us standing fans
turning them on maximum so we can try to
work try to function because we got
nowhere to go
Tuesday morning rolls around and the guy
to fix the AC unit he has the parts he
replaces two or three parts in the AC
unit but he opens it up a little bit
more than he had before and he tells me
you need to replace the entire unit now
it might work for a day might work for a
week hell it might work for a year but
your AC unit is not safe so you were
just told for your AC unit was a ticking
time bomb how did that make you feel
awful like everything else in this house
has made me feel it can't just be a
simple fix we've been in the hottest
period of the summer no air conditioning
and now we're told yeah you might have
company coming in but it's gonna take a
week or two to get the paperwork in
order and to get the AC unit order and
get it out here that AC unit never came
it's a home warranty company wouldn't
approve it because technically the AC
units currently functioning doesn't
matter if it will be tomorrow it doesn't
matter if the unit's even safely
functioning it's working why would we
pay to fix it
[Music]
my job is to determine I'm not here to
judge the whole day I a dance as a kid I
have not killed eight people or anything
sometimes bugs get in the house you
haven't killed any people I hid a
raccoon on the way home once no people
let's say for the sake of argument that
you didn't that means that somehow this
was either put here by forces beyond our
control or it was already in the house
Wednesday July 24th Molly's parents are
in town but I still have to work as I
said every Wednesday
so I'm playing D&D Molly and her parents
are sitting upstairs watching TV when
all of a sudden bang made that noise
they looked around couldn't find
anything I had no idea it happened I had
my headphones on I was in a call didn't
even know what occurred Thursday we're
sitting around watching TV in the
evening another noise this time I heard
it nothing upstairs nothing downstairs
unexplained until Friday Friday we went
to leave the house the house said no
it's not gonna be that simple
open the garage door didn't laying on
the ground in front of me a big metal
wire the house had struck again more and
more frequent each time it hits we're
talking to a/c unit goes out the very
next week garage door it's no longer
leaks it's of all like a virus the house
doesn't want us to leave it doesn't want
to be fixed it just wants suffering so I
call a garage door repair company can
they come out today they'll be out
tomorrow but they need to know what's
the spring look like I don't know much
about garage doors just like I had know
much about drywall or kitchen faucets or
bathroom faucets or whirlpools but he
tells me to go look above the garage or
first spring I see a spring I see -
that's weird he told me there'd only be
one oh our spring split in half July
26th the garage door repair company
shows up they replaced the spring they
replaced the wires and I'm waiting for
the bad news
but the bad news doesn't come it's fixed
this is the first time this has happened
where someone came in and fixed the
problem July 29th the painters come to
paint the drywall in the room that
refuses to be repaired 9:30 in the
morning
the painters come in I open the double
doors I take a deep breath I closed my
eyes I prepare for the worst what the
ceiling isn't dripping the floor isn't
met they paint they leave they're done
nothing new has gone wrong
whatever the curse the spirit the
poltergeist the demon whatever it's gone
it's finally gone I'm gonna ask you this
did any plumber
any-any actually give you an answer as
to what was causing the answer as to
what caused it not one of these people
in the year and a half your house has
been going through this ordeal has told
you what caused the problem there's a
garage door literally everything else
was a complete mystery you shut off the
water main
and water still weak yeah yeah and no
one had an explanation for that they
thought that water might have been like
already in the ceiling at that point but
they couldn't figure out what made it
get there why the water can come back
out of the shower and they've no
explanation for that you see these
things are the things that your mind
justifies you are comfortable now
because you think it's over I guarantee
you this will never be over until you
find the source okay I'm not here to
tell you how to do anything I'm not a
problem solver I'm a problem finder and
I think I've found the problem so my job
here is done
I will bill you thank you for your time
didn't hire you died but the pilot I
what I wait I didn't you may think
that's the end of the story you may
think that it's all over now
what have you learned from this
adventure the evil never dies
the ending is not yet written July 29th
the final repair is made on Wade's roof
the leak is patched the drywall painted
everything is whole again and just when
it seems that the curse of water has
been washed away for good little did we
know that the curse has simply been
passed on
July 29th 2019 my house started with
normal morning all day woke up it did my
morning routine breakfast late on my
phone for like three hours normal stuff
normal day finally got around time for
me to head up to the office right as I
was about to reach for the office door I
guess something struck me and I was like
feel like something's out of place you
know you just get that bad feeling reach
down push the handle down walked into
the office as soon as I hit the light
switch there was on the ceiling water
spot not really big but you know it was
there everything else in the office was
fine water anywhere nothing was wet it
was it was weird honestly it was it was
like the leak came from nowhere a leak
over an office full of computers is
concerning so I checked it out I got I
got the ladder I picked up in in the
Attic
nothing nothing was even blessed oh I
got a repair guy and a repair guy came
in I'm Doug
he dug around and and really got in
there he found a spot in the attic above
where the water stain was bone-dry
looked like it had never been wet since
the day they built the house he said it
was fine and I pointed pointed at the
water spot and I said what do you how
are you gonna tell me it's fine and he
said look buddy there's no leaks there's
nothing wrong and he left to this day I
don't know how the hell there's a water
spot on the ceiling of the office it
doesn't make it he got the incense I've
spent nights sitting in here with the
lights off listening for leaks look
where all the water pipes go
nothing I've I've stared at that stupid
stain on the ceiling both during the day
and in my dreams for so many hours that
I swear to God I have the son-of-a-bitch
memorized and there's no earthly reason
why that water stain is on the ceiling
of my office it doesn't make any sense
unless I can figure this out unless I
can put this to rest just just in here
just mentally I don't know if I'm gonna
be able to live in this house I don't
know if this is gonna work for me that
god damn stain is ruining my life I
blame Wade the creature that haunts this
house that kills you emotionally it
kills you mentally it takes away your
sanity your hope it drains you of
everything and hopes that the rest will
just take care of itself if you have the
option to pass this curse thank you for
watching this sordid tale of despair and
woe I hope you enjoyed it if you did
mayhaps you'd like to commemorate this
experience of suffering with this
delightful design that showcases Wade at
his most pure moment of suffering right
only available for a limited amount of
time and only available for a limited
quantity so act fast because it's very
likely that this shirt is already gone
and don't worry because none of the
proceeds go to me Oh No
leggo directly to a man who is suffering
the most in this entire ordeal mr. Wade
Barnes himself
so if you'd like to support a poor man
who suffers poorly check the link in the
description below but I recommend you
act quickly because once this shirt gets
washed away it'll never be seen again
and so ends the story of poor Wade
Barnes but fade never rests and demons
never sweep so until next time I will
see you
in the next video bye-bye
[Music]